Es ist wirklich ein absolut irres ding der deutsche mathematiker peter scholze gehört zu den besten der welt
er wurde jetzt mit der fields medaille ausgezeichnet es ist die höchste auszeichnung
die mathematiker halten können wird nur alle vier jahre vergeben und gilt demnach als
nobelpreis für mathematik wofür hat er sie bekommen jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Peter scholze gilt als mozart unter den mathematikern erst wirklich in der lage
neue theorien oder beweise aus dem ärmel zu schütteln
er macht etwas was einfach niemand so außer ihm kann bei mozart ist bekannt dass er so gearbeitet hat der komponist
komponierte an einem tag drei klavierkonzerte im kopf und brauchte dann wochen um sie auf notenpapier
festzuhalten und genauso ist es bei peter scholze
inspiriert vom vortrag eines kollegen aber ein beweis komplett im kopf entwickelt um ihn dann in sechs monaten aufzuschreiben und er ab so
funktioniert so ein mathe professor
michael rapoport und hier geht es nicht um punkt oder strich rechnung scholze beschäftigt sich mit wirklich
hoch komplexen problemen wie zum beispiel den
perfekten räumen die entwickelte er selbst in seiner doktorarbeit damit können probleme aus der zahlentheorie
mit diesem
geometrischen ansatz bewiesen werden ein neues werkzeug für mathematiker und mathematikerinnen
ein bisschen so als würde man sich die kurve einer formel ansehen und sie dadurch viel besser
verstehen peter scholze hatte als kind schon die besten startbedingungen mathematik lernte er an einer in der ddr gegründeten
spezialschule die hochbegabten beste bedingungen bietet der heinrich hertz schule hier in berlin friedrichshain
zitat ich war im matheunterricht immer recht gut ja das sagt
scholze etwas bescheiden über seine zeit dort er ist auf der ewigen bestenliste
der
internationalen mathematik olympiade auf rang elf dreimal gewann er gold und einmal silber
zitat mir war von anfang an klar dass er ein
außergewöhnliches talent ist so sein mathe professor michael rapoport bei dem er an der universität bonn seinen master gemacht hat
und diese maßarbeit hat stolze in nur fünf monaten geschrieben zitat sie war so außerordentlich dass ich sie gleich an kollegen geschickt habe
allerdings kann otto
normalverbraucher mit den forschungen scholz es rein gar nichts anfangen er arbeitet in den bereichen der reinen mathematik nichts davon ist
praxisbezogen und wenn mal eine seiner methoden in der praxis anwendung finden würde dann wäre das reiner zufall
wenn es dazu kommen sollte dann erwarb das natürlich hier bei klicks und wenn er kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann um geht ihr die etwas
unzuverlässiger abo boxee auf youtube und er verpasst kann wie du denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich und auch andere messenger von jedem
upload und zwar noch vor allen an und zwar täglich und
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal krieg zum social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber
nicht die
genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch dort klicken deutsches mathe genie beweis alte formel bis dann
bleibt dran